what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we have about a month before
Dark Knight's metal five comes out and
in truth I'd actually kind of planned on
holding Hawkman found until halfway
through January and then releasing it
and then giving ourselves about another
two weeks before we could do Dark
Knight's mantle number five well you
guys have been screaming for this so
I'll give it to you just be aware
there's no comics for Dark Knights metal
coming out for a month kind of how it
goes so and it's kind of weird I mean
there's no there's nothing coming out I
mean there's no tie ends no nothing for
the whole month of January
there's nothing but but there's like no
Dark Knight's metal of any kind being
released so it's gonna be kind of a lull
but you know that's I guess it's what
you guys wanted because you guys want
this story now so so hot man found is is
really really cool this is like a very
Twilight Zone ESCA episode fun fact
so before the ball dropped on New Year's
Eve last night we were watching the
first two episodes of Twilight Zone
because it's on Netflix myself and Benny
were just kind of killing time and we
fired up the first two episodes one of
the guys who is with us mark has never
seen the twilight zone we were like dude
that's crazy
the entire modern genre of like sci-fi
thrillers were surprise endings was
built on the shoulders of Rod Sterling's
Twilight Zone like it's one of the best
shows ever in the history of television
so we just kind of astounded me we felt
like giving him a hard time but this is
very Twilight Zone esque in terms of how
this works because initially it just
kind of picks up with Hawkman falling
from the sky
now remember Hawkman was taken by
Barbados but we didn't really know what
happened to him all we knew was that
there was basically this journal of
Hawkman kind of going around you know
and doing all these different things
work he was trying to track down the the
nature of enth metal because remember
for years and years and years in DC
Comics no one ever knew what if metal
was about all they knew he was just like
this metal that existed and it had some
properties to it and different people
use different different purposes Hawk
man's mace was made of implemental you
had Deathstroke who had implemented
armor and that was really about it it's
not really until Dark Knight's metal
came along there's suddenly there was
this huge expansion for what in metal
means and what it's about what it's
capable of and all that kind of stuff
this story is designed to kind of
provide the back end to DC which we
never saw that it was basically
somewhere along the line after Hawkman
had basically discovered info metal and
in turn was kind of thrown into the
scenario where he was going to die and
be reborn really until the end of time
that his curiosity piqued his question
was what is it about
that puts me in this situation that I'm
going to die and be reborn that no
matter who kills me or how many times I
die I'll always come back in a different
body and live a new life Dark Knight's
medal is designed to explore that whole
thing and so really with Hawkman going
through and trying to figure out what's
going on
with regards to his first encounter with
Barbados to feeding Barbados different
things like that
this led into him basically discovering
that in metal you know really originates
from the dark multiverse and so in the
the dark knights metal stories you know
issues one and two and so on he'd walked
through the portal and we never found
out what happened to him this is
designed to provide that back into fill
I mean it's very much a filler story I
mean Batman lost was a filler story it's
not really designed to move the plot
forward so much as it's designed to say
here's just a story about what happened
with one of the characters and so
initially with Hawkman just kind of
falling from the sky he really throws it
in as a dream of sorts simply saying
like I have this dream that I'm a
warrior you know I'm a I'm a Hawkman you
know and I fly to the sky and I'm
fighting for what's right and then I
fall to the ground from the sky every
single time he has a stream he wakes up
right before he hits the ground and it's
super cool because what this does is it
kind of shows us what happened in this
interim period between the time when he
hits the ground and the time when he
takes to the sky again he's basically
among a multitude of people who have all
been taken captive now the initial
indication here is that Hawkman is not
the only person to have ever been taken
by Barbados that there are a litany of
people from all throughout different
points in time who have been taken and
thrown into the dark multiverse and all
of them exist as prisoners of sorts now
each and every single day these jailers
more or less these hawk people
effectively show up they grab some
prisoner and they whisk off with them
and the goal of Hawkman is to capture
one of them and finally make it to their
ship finally find a way to bring these
guys down and I'll essentially allow all
these individuals who are held captive
to go free and it's cool because this
follows perfectly in line with the
nature of his character over you know
because of the fact that Hawkman will
die by whatever manner and whatever
means he'll die of old age or he'll die
in combat or something along those lines
and his essence will be reborn in a new
body he's fought in countless battles
he's one of the fiercest warriors out
there in DC Comics that's why if you go
and you read something like injustice
for example Hawkman kept coming back he
was just like this fierce battle
hardened guy who would keep facing off
against Superman and injustice when DC
released those lines of stories they
grabbed Hawkman as he existed in the
main line DC set of stories and rolled
the character over so you
really see any major differentiation in
the nature of how he was written he was
very much the same way and so with this
whole scenario things play out exactly
as we would expect them to he's able to
subdue one of these guys you know he
initially tries to defeat him he can't
really take the wings and use them for
his own ends so he literally just climbs
up the side of a mountain and finally
makes his way on to the ship itself and
again it's this dream that he has he
keeps recurring he always ends up
falling but in his mind is the scenario
not this time and that's why it's so
cool because what this indicates is that
that's his biggest fear that he'll
always fall down
he always imagines himself going into
this ship or trying to try to gain
access to this ship but ultimately end
up being beaten so as one of these
things were kind of conquering his own
fears conquering his own nightmares and
then ultimately you know being
successful and freeing his people and so
having finally stowed aboard this ship
or you know finally gained access is
basically all these weapons that belong
to all these people all these maces
different things like that and even the
armor of himself and so that's why he
basically put the oh he dons his Hawkman
suit he becomes the hero were most
familiar with and he begins this
campaign to basically destroy these guys
now of course this leads into a direct
conflict with kind of like the chief of
the Hawkman so to speak he'll kind of
like their leader or the very least one
of the guys who were in charge you know
military wise but it is interesting
because it's essentially the same idea
that he's facing off against this guy
he's defeating this guy you know he does
what he always does destroys this enemy
destroys all these different Hawkman all
these different soldiers that are out
there so on and so forth it's always the
same thing it's him defeating the bad
guy the nature of his character that's
why it's cool and that's why it's
interesting because it feeds into how we
always saw Hawkman with regards to DC
Comics and so finally defeating this guy
finally getting aboard this ship he
sails up to the sky he dons his armor
says look we are free now sails up into
the sky and starts crashing back down to
the ground again and that's when the
realism of this situation begins to come
into sharp relief
it's the repeating dream it never ends
he never escapes from it this dream that
he has where he takes him to the sky and
he manages to lose his wings and come
crashing to the ground
that's how it always happens he's stuck
in an endless perpetual loop so long as
he's confined to this role of being the
you know guard of the world forts like
we saw on dark nights metal Fork Hawkman
will always have the dream that he'll
take to the sky to defeat these people
who are capturing you know quote unquote
the individuals who are being held
captive he'll always defeat them and
he'll always gain his freedom and you
always crash back down to the surface
again it will always in that way none of
its real
it's all a dream no one else is being
held captive by Barbados at least not
that we know of it's basically a way to
keep his mind in stasis is the exact
same thing that happened to like Batman
is the exact same thing that happened to
Superman before he was able to engineer
his escape it's the exact same thing
that goes on with these characters time
and time again they're held captive and
they're made to believe they have a
chance at success and that's why the
actions and the abilities of Barbados
work here because it's essentially
breaking a person down at the very least
it keeps them preoccupied and they're
totally unaware to the realism of the
situation but it basically keeps them
occupied it keeps them kind of in stasis
in their mind they're living a matrix
like mindset everything they experience
is real everything they experience is
true and it can break them
psychologically all the while they're
off doing something according to
whatever it is Barbados wants them to do
and that's why it's interesting that's
why it's so intriguing because what this
really does is it hints of the idea that
because of the fact that you know
Hawkman is the guard of the world force
meaning he's basically the person that's
designed to eliminate any threat that
would show up and try to stop the
actions of Barbados from basically
conquering the entirety of the positive
multiverse while he's outside of the
dark multiverse it really throws in this
idea that Hawkman as he exists now is
the most powerful tool that Barbados has
at his disposal the most powerful being
he has available I mean after all why
would you give the keys to the house to
somebody who couldn't protect it but
again it's interesting it is pretty
intriguing it's not huge there's not a
whole lot to go on here you know it's a
pretty interesting story more or less
just kind of one of those fillers
stories you just sort of breeze through
and call it a day
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explained to
make sure you guys with the sub button
to become part of the Rob cork you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]